well john david peterson 25 years old he
was the mets first round pick three
years ago out of the university of
oregon and as you can see tonight makes
just his eighth career big league start
lacuna aboard right away here is freddie
freeman here's the o2
now number one first strikeout for david
peterson
one-on-one on for marcelo zuna
snap throw to first and they got him two
away
absolutely perfect timing
he climbs the ladder on him a couple of
strikeouts for peterson who works around
that lead-off walk ian anderson 22 years
old john third overall by atlanta four
years ago making only his fifth ever big
league start three straight walks to
begin the home first nimo conforto and
davis base is still loaded for robinson
cadone the author of 11 career grand
slams
chopping and it finds left field nemo is
in conforto is coming home to score
robinson canoe finds left field and he
gives the mets an early two-nothing lead
yeah he didn't hit it very hard but he
didn't need to as he found the spot
off walk duval the double one out two in
scoring position to dansby swanson 3-2
and a strikeout that went away in
second and third two down
number eight man third baseman austin
reilly
[Applause]
and here he goes
what a job by the rookie david peterson
so where does ian anderson go after that
33 pitch first inning new andres jimenez
chasing up out of the zone second
strikeout for ian anderson one out here
in the bottom of the second
three pitches all strikes chorinos who's
had a tough time with the bat this year
is caught looking and it's back-to-back
strikeouts
here in the home second
great year for conforto
cut on and missed
instep stanzby swanson
here comes his 1-2
it's another strikeout boy the off-speed
pitch gets swatson eight punch-outs for
peterson has matched a career-high
one-on-one on for robinson chirinos and
he has not been swinging a hot stick
this year only two extra base hits all
season
this one gets past riley
and it's out of the corner
jimenez flying around he's getting waved
in coming past third
torinos drives in a run with just his
third extra base hit this season
and it's a three-nothing mess lead
david peterson is trying to become the
first met this year not named degrom
with double-digit strikeouts he has nine
of them
what a night for david peterson the
rookie lefty a career best 10 strikeouts
and quick work there's two outs here in
the sixth he is coming in at the right
time for the mets adam duvall match
sailing
deep and gone
adam duvall homers again it's his 11th
this month and he is tied an all-time
braves record
his 11th home run in the month of
september
it ties the
1959 month of september from the hall of
famer eddie matthews into aussie albies
into center
limo able to get to it to end the top of
the six just one run over six he strikes
out at career best 10. again the mets
cannot nor can rojas let this game slip
away dansby swanson the lead off double
riley just drew a walk punya has all the
power of the world also has one of the
best walk rates in baseball
and he lays off bases are loaded freddy
freeman facing wilson
[Applause]
hard hit right to canoe option pass to
second on to first
wilson doesn't take many pitches he gets
two for the price of one jerry's familia
will take over and work the eight one
out for travis darno
swings at the first pitch and rides it
out to center
this ball is gone
number nine for travis darneau the
former met
and he brings his new ball club within a
run in the eighth inning
shane green an all-star last year with
the tigers now
with the atlanta braves we'll work the
bottom of the eight fish of dominick
smith
smith
rides this out towards the gap dominic
smith has this kid over the wall for a
home run
number nine on the season for dominic
smith enjoying a breakout campaign
that's a big run for the match it's a
two-run lead
[Applause]
now canoe sucks this out to right field
robinson canola leaves the yard
back to back home runs for the mets in
the bottom of the eighth pino the latest
his ninth faces are loaded for nemo
swinging away on the first pitch it
finds right field
mcneil is in to score jimenez is coming
home and he strides across the plate as
well
nemo pushes two across and the mets now
lead it seven to two in the eighth